il y a tant à faire et il reste si peu
de temps alors les commerçants s'efforce
de tout prévoir de ne rien négliger
chez bouvreuils meubles la direction a
fait appel à une infirmière pour former
les employés
on a fait installer un avait beau
fonctionnel pour avoir une station de
lavage au centre de l'accueil on a eu de
la signalisation partout j'ai acheté des
visières pour l'ensemble de mes employés
on a mis de l'alcool pour nettoyer de
désinfectant chez pierrois chaussures un
petit panier a été préparé avec soin
pour les clients on va avoir une paire
de gants pour ceux qui sont peut-être un
peu moins secure on a les outils pour
enfiler les chaussures et on a une
petite paire de bas je t'aime beaucoup
beaucoup de stress chez cubique le défi
à relever est de taille
comment permettre aux clients d'acheter
des vêtements de façon sécuritaire qui
vont aller en cabine mais faut
désinfecter la cabine avant qu'il rend
après qu'il soit sorti faut mettre les
vêtements comme en quarantaine comme
1,48 à qui on n'a personne vaut pour lui
toucher
lorsqu'on demande à ses commerçants de
saint jean sur richelieu si la décision
de rouvrir les magasins et judicieuse il
affiche un optimisme prudent
les gens sont impatients les gens
déménagent les gens ont des projets
quand même et je pense qu'il faut le
faire un moment donné c'est beaucoup de
préparation c'est beaucoup de
questionnements c'est de l'inconnu
je pense que c'est important de faire
des tests en ce moment j'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils attendent plus
longtemps les situations vraiment
changer du jour au lendemain j'espère
que tout le monde arrive la première
journée en même temps on a besoin white
knight un petit peu sécurisé la chambre
de commerce de la région de cache pas
son inquiétude je pense que ça se fait
un petit peu rapidement selon moi mais
par contre si on regarde du côté des
entrepreneurs une pression où chacun
jours ou semaines qu'on est couvert sur
les résultats financiers pour préparer
cette reprise d activité les entreprises
n'ont ménagé ni les efforts ni les
ressources chez bouverot immeuble
l'opération a coûté près de 10 mille
dollars
si maxime bertrand radio-canada ça jean
sur richelieu